hi i'm alana glazer and i'm sophia bush
and we are here with buzzfeed to take
the co-star test
and this is on behalf of our film false
positive
which i uh co-wrote and starred in and
produced
yes she wears all the hats
first one i'm just like i think i need
to find the answer with you if you will
yeah no i feel the same i was actually
going to ask you i think we met in this
city around
gramercy park ish yeah
like 2016 in new york wow first scene
that we ever filmed together
i remember just being so excited because
we've been talking about the movie
and then watching you be in this
character who was so
different and withheld we were in that
cafe
maybe it was in brooklyn and remember we
first shot it outside and it was
freezing and the wind was crazy
and we couldn't get it together and then
we had to re-shoot it inside because
remember also when you
every time you entered the scene like a
stormy wind and clouds
come it looked like we had incredible
production value it just didn't work and
we re-shot it
i felt like cruella deville because
every time i walked in the wind would be
like
i was like i feel like we get a yes on
that
okay what was their first acting job
your first acting job
couldn't have been one tree hill you
must have done little things leading
up to one tree hill which i don't know
the answer to
i don't know your first acting job
either in my head i was like oh well my
first acting job was this scene in ben
wilder that i did with ryan reynolds
which like great way to start in
hollywood the nicest man alive
then when you said that i was like oh no
i got my sag card because in high school
i did a kit kat commercial
and i've never done one before and i
didn't know that because you have to
literally eat candy bars for three days
you spit cups because you eat like a
hundred kitkats a day
and nobody told me and so four hours
into the first day i was like i'm really
i think i'm gonna be sick
and the girl next to me was like have
you not been spitting them out and i was
like nobody told me to do that
hilarious it becomes toxic after a
certain
point like actual poison yeah so mine
was um i think my first
paid acting job was like not even ddr
but like a dance dance revolution copy
cat
thing we were all dancing in an
abandoned mall in new jersey
it was a glamorous entry into this
industry
also what you didn't realize is that you
apparently set the stage for tick tock
what would a tick tocker give to have an
abandoned mall to do a dance routine
oh my god good call you're welcome
tick-tock
okay so we didn't we didn't get that one
i'm gonna be real
strict about this okay what was their
favorite scene to
shoot in false positive okay i think i
have one okay i would say
yours is the confrontation
in the hallway yes that's what i was
gonna say is that yours too
no oh really i liked it so much that i
projected that you like did the best
also
my favorite with you was the like when
we did the reshoots
inside at the cafe and i was like really
going nuts
and you were like you're sick it was
like the most
gas lady it felt insane
every time when we were in that cafe you
and i would get to the end of a scene
and both just go
oh no no no no we were so grossed out
yeah i'm like thinking about it now you
know i'm starting to sweat i'm getting
anxious
i was frightening i got that one oh my
gosh dream actor to work with
do we say each other because we want to
make another movie
sophia bush great the goal is to just
work with as many different awesome
people as possible totally there are
different
people whether it's actors or directors
or writers that i would love to work
with because i want
their kind of hot take on what's going
on in the world around me
this is a good question to take with me
to the next
set where i'm like who's your doctor to
work with or whatever
people will be like damn you know the
biz cool question
okay what are they usually doing in
between takes
i would say sophia
is always organizing for social justice
between her takes that's what you're
doing the same for you we'd be on our
phones like did you see this did you see
what just happened in georgia
and we're like crafting instagram
captions together the other option is
again because you did
literally wear a crown on the set
because you wrote it
and produced it and starred in it you
had like producers
to do but you were either doing producer
things
or we were like comparing notes on
social justice
actions no i was taking notes on your
cruel justice representation that's very
kind and also you
kill that we won that one you won that
one okay
clear coffee order i don't know to your
point i was
doing a bunch of i don't know what your
coffee order is what is your coffee
order ice almond milk latte
i'm gonna remember that for next time i
love a macchiato kind of anything i'll
take milk or
nut milk i don't think we win that one
no i don't know when your birthday is
i was just gonna say i can google your
birthday i don't know either
when's your birthday my birthday is july
8th coming up
cancer yeah i think my baby's gonna be a
cancer which is going to say i think
we're going to be very close my baby no
my birthday
is april 12th i'm an aries cancer is the
crab
it's like a full water baby i'm like
water moon
all the tides all the things which leads
to being really sensitive and sensitive
to other people's energy and then i'm
like
a ferocious defender love that is clear
about you
it's easy for me to be out on the front
lines for others
but i'm actually personally very
introverted what is
favorite tv show in our movie this is
the hardest question for me because i
feel like
when parents say i could never pick a
favorite child i'm like who could pick
their
favorite piece of art ever i'm just
gonna like share one of my favorite
movies of all time
one of them like you're saying but mrs
doubtfire
iconic it's just iconic robin williams
was
my like favorite comedic genius of all
time his
live on broadway stand up special that
he did it's unbelievable
i was obsessed with orphan black yes
tatiana muslim yes oh my god tatiana's
beyond
i met her and literally was a buffoon
and she was so nice like i'm sweating
and i don't know what to do and i'm
not supposed to because we do the same
thing for the living but i can't i
words don't i'm so sorry and she was
like i really appreciate it and i was
like yep i'm going to see myself out
is that an acting warrior on earth i
will never
understand how she did that i think
we're probably around a half
yeah you know a lot you've been friends
for a while now
you know all of the basics and then some
you can't wait to become even closer as
the years go
on that part is true i got a 4 out of 10
and same description
calling you out buzzfeed you won
5 out of 10. thank you buzzfeed
and be sure to catch false positive on
hulu i might have
like given us extra points for things
but honestly i love it
that's sort of the point
[Music]
[Music]
you